son los habitantes originarios de la
isla los canas un pueblo con tradiciones
milenarias pero en
1853 llegaron los primeros colonizadores
y tomaron posición del territorio
diezmada por las enfermedades o
masacrada durante las revueltas la
población kanak se divide en dos en
pocos años los caldos descendientes de
los colonos blancos eran más numerosos
en la década de 1980 la cuestión de la
independencia se convirtió en un tema
central el 22 de abril de 1988 un
atentado provocó un giro dramático
militante es canar atacaron a las
fuerzas de seguridad matando a cuatro
soldados el independentista romaric bau
y el anti independentistas la clase
quemaron finalmente el 26 de junio de
1988 el acuerdo de matt kim jong un
pacto basado en la organización de un
referéndum de autodeterminación y en la
redistribución de las riquezas
yo hemos conseguido entender cada uno de
nosotros que debemos saber dar y
perdonar concejalas venir creo que el
futuro reconocerá que estos acuerdos
fueron un paso importante como consistía
para aportó el líder kanak pagó con su
vida este intento de reconciliación fue
asesinado el 4 de mayo de 1989 por un
extremista de su mismo grupo étnico el
acuerdo de número firmado en
1998 ratificó la organización de un
referéndum de autodeterminación en tres
etapas y con una transferencia de
competencias 20 años después como
previsto por el acuerdo se realizó una
primera consulta el 4 de noviembre de
2018 el
56% rechazó la idea de independencia dos
años después volvió a ganar el no de
acuerdo con el pacto de nube a la
tercera y última etapa de esta consulta
popular debería haberse celebrado en
septiembre de 2022 pero parís lo ha
adelantado para este domingo